les proches comme toi temps sont très
très proches on savait que plus on
allait partager mais que ce soit une
bière le soir en fin de journée ou après
parfois on arrive et on discutait de
tout de rien et parfois bien des regards
il ya c'est un truc qui nous faisait
penser à mais ça en fait dans le film
c'est intéressant ça faut qu'on la
ramène
et on avait le même objectif qui on est
et on n'était pas uniquement sur le film
on échanger sur nos vies sur nos sur nos
centres d'intérêt sont un peu tout et on
est vraiment devenu très proche mais ma
part des finances est identique est beau
dans ce film je crois que c'était un
film qui ne qui n'a pas ça pour un jeu
leur sexualité
oui c'est plutôt de l'ordre de 100 fiche
un peu que ça soit deux garçons sera
peut être deux filles sera peut être
agréable ça peut être n'importe quoi ce
qui est intéressant c'est la rencontre
de ces deux personnes et comment l'un et
l'autre s'apprivoise en faisant le film
et même en le voyant c'est cette
histoire d'amour elle me plait elle me
donne vraiment quelle que soit je pense
que l'orientation sexuelle de la
personne je pense vraiment que ça que
c'est une histoire d'amour qui donne
envie on a tous envie de vivre ça ce
premier amour qui est très beau très
solaire avec un psy pas une une personne
qui nous fascine comme ça je crois qu'il
ya deux manières de se confronter un peu
la mort était peu à cet âge là c'est la
première qui est de l ess enfermés là
dedans avec une crainte et l'autre qui
est plutôt de s'en échapper et
d'ailleurs à contre-courant en plein
dans la vie je vois que nos deux
personnages justement ils vont ils font
ces deux et carla et malgré tout vous
n'avez pas se rencontrer et s'interroger
sur la vision de chacun
et puis c'est marrant personnellement
moi j'avais l'impression que j'avais
plus peur de la mort quand j'étais
vraiment enfants et quand je n'ai jamais
quand j'avais jamais été confronté à la
mort